[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when I meet people and I tell them that
I'm a professor
they were only surprised because of how
small I am and because I was a job girl
on the news my name is Norah Phoenix
Diana I'm the well first he jumped
pro-wrestler milo from wrestling begin
when I was 14 I sold that was when I
started playing W video games with my
brother
so from that I started watching
wrestling on TV like every week so I
wasn't like maybe I can try pro
wrestling but at first I don't have
enough confident to join pro wrestling
because I was hijab they were lighting
again he tell order hijab there's no
excuse for me to not pursue what I am
passionate about their work it is and
they say that I cannot wrestling because
a woman's gonna do an extreme sport but
for me I don't really mind them because
some people underestimate me
it motivates me and challenge me to work
better
[Music]
in malaysia pro-wrestling we only have
one course I ask infections occur when I
first started he didn't treat me
differently because I was a girl like
that I was bring the job he treated me
just like the guys we train twice a week
usually within for about 4 to 6 hours
and during the training we do 2 hours of
cardio I was firm enough and then 4
hours of rest until in real life like
you know I'm just a ordinary goodbye
when I do resting I can be like somebody
else like a different person as I came
Allah I fed the energy from the crowd
and I become
[Applause]
I'm the first female in Malaysia
harassing people a championship when I
went viral I got a lot of messages
telling me thank you and they say that I
give them more confidence about cars or
missing woman's investing especially
looking goiters
we have a tree with same job girl coming
for a tryout and they said you're
inspired by me which is amazing to be
the face of nature per se it's something
that I'm a historical I'm going to do
but
[Music]